hello again everyone so for the second
talk of the day we have professor khan
from uiuc who's going to build on the
first talk on mdps and talk more about
reinforcement learning
thank you uh
like to thank wayna for a great
introduction
so
when i talked about markov decision
processes and how to obtain an optimal
policy if you're given the probability
transition matrix
so the problem i'm going to talk about
is typically what's called reinforcement
learning where
you you don't know the probability
transition matrix so in particular i'm
going to first look at the simplest
reinforcement learning problem which is
where you're given a policy pi
so pi is a policy which specifies the
probability with which you take action a
when you're in state s
okay and associated with this policy
there's something called a q function
which basically says that if i'm in
state s and take action a at this point
and from the next step onwards i'm using
policy pi
then what is the value function so this
is also it's either called the q
function or the state action value
function and v is just the state value
function
okay
so my goal is to
estimate
this q function
without knowing the probability
transition matrix
so if the probability transition matrix
is known as
wayna pointed out
you can think of this
as some operator
q pi is some operator times q pi so i'm
abusing notation and using t pi also for
the q function operator she used it for
the value function operator
and t pi is a contraction mapping so
therefore you can just iterably start
from some
any q and then substitute back to get
the
true q function
so what i am going to do is what happens
if
this is the node
okay
it's a problem clear
so we're trying to estimate the q
function for a fixed policy
when the probability transition matrix
is unknown
and
as i'll
demonstrate later on
this fixed policy idea sort of pervades
a lot of reinforcement learning when you
try to find the optimal policy the
algorithms look similar whether you use
value iteration based algorithms or
policy iteration based algorithms for
reinforcement learning all of them are
built on the basic idea that i'm going
to mention here okay
for now i'm going to assume that we are
going to estimate the entire q function
for every state action pair
so the number of states the number of
actions could be very very large in
which case this won't be feasible
so you use something called function
approximation in that setting and i will
talk about function approximation later
on so right now i'm going to consider
what's called the tabular case so where
you try to estimate the q function for
every value of s and a and that's called
tabular
tabular learning so i'm going to stick
with tabular learning for right now
okay
okay so what is the algorithm
so first of all let me specify what the
data is
so the data is
run the policy
pi
and then you
observe the state and actions
okay
and you may not even know what the
policy pi is i mean like if you think of
how
tesla for example gathers data you just
drive it around in the in some city and
then you see all the states and actions
okay so under some policy pi we're
observing the states and actions so s0
is the initial state a0 is initial
action and then it makes the markup a
decision process transition to an s1 and
then you take a new action a1 and so on
and so you have t steps of data t
of data from t time steps and the goal
is to learn
q pi from this
okay it's clear
so what is the algorithm the algorithm
is this and i'll explain what the
motivation for it is
so if
you observe
at state k at time k let's say the state
action you observe is sna
and
at the next time step
observe s prime and a prime let's say
then what you do is
you update
the q function the estimate of the q
function this q is going to be the
estimate of q pi
okay so you
update it in the following manner
so the previous estimate that you had
plus
by the way for simplicity i'm going to
assume r is deterministic given s and a
r r is not random but you can also allow
randomness here but for simplicity of
notation and so on i just assume that
this is uh
deterministic
so for the state that i observe
i update the q function
and for all other state and action pairs
i'm not updating the q function
the clear
and what is the rationale behind this
algorithm so basically you're changing
changing the q function slowly your
estimate of the q function very slowly
so epsilon k should be thought of as a
small number
right it could potentially depend on
time you could have time varying epsilon
so you know or you could use fixed
epsilon
so the idea is that you put a lot of
weight on the current estimate
and
what you do here is that your estimate
of the q function when the probability
distribution is unknown is just simply r
plus gamma
times q
okay so but i put a small weight on that
because that's a random quantity okay
and i don't believe in it as much so
therefore it is just a a
convex combination of the two and it's
not it's not
uh um
it's actually the same thing as the law
of large numbers
or how to estimate the mean
so if you have uh
t realizations of a random variable
independent realizations of a random
variable this can be written of course
is
and which can further be written as
right
so this is you're putting this is your
previous estimate
after t minus one observations and you
put a small weight on it
and then put a sorry put a large weight
on it and put a small weight on your new
estimate
okay
so this
way of estimating
uh uh
random quantities is called stochastic
approximation this was a very old
history uh i think uh robbins was
mentioned
uh
yesterday in uh in the context of uh
uh
multi-armed bandits the same robins who
also came up with stochastic
approximation robinson mandrell
correct correct there will be conditions
on epsilon k for which you have
convergence
uh but often people are not interested
necessarily in
convergence you're going to stop it
after a finite amount of time so there
are different types of step sizes that
are analyzed
um so i might uh
yeah so let's just let's look at the
let's now worry about the conditions in
epsilon k but you can think of it as one
over k for example for right now
okay so this is
the stochastic approximation
algorithm
for estimating the q function
okay
um
but i want to say something which is
peculiar here
this is what might be called an
asynchronous algorithm because you're
only updating one element of the q
vector the q vector
is
a vector
of dimension
s times a where s is the size of the
state space and a is the size of the
action space right but at each time i'm
only updating one element of the
a q vector
okay
and and so so it's not it's not so the
diff that's why it's slightly harder to
analyze than this right here we just
have one parameter you're trying to
estimate here i have a vector i'm trying
to estimate and i'm estimating one
element of the i'm updating one element
of the vector each time okay so we still
have to show the same ideas like law of
large numbers hold here as well
yeah
okay
um it's probably more convenient
should i just stick to the middle maybe
i'll try to stick to the middle as much
as possible
sorry
oh you can still see it there okay
as long as what there's a lower bound oh
yeah yeah there's a lower point here
that's true
so qk plus 1 sa
can be written as qksa
minus epsilon k
indicator
a k
equal to s a
of
k s a
minus r s a
minus
indicator
sk plus 1
ak plus 1
s prime a prime
okay
so i'm basically just
only updating the parts of the
uh queue function that i have the states
and actions that i observe okay
so
if i define
in vector notation the whole thing can
be written more compactly
and you'll start seeing why it looks
like
the bellman equation for a fixed policy
in a second
suppose i take
the entire vector q
okay
and i can write it as qk plus 1
is qk
minus
epsilon
times
d0k
uk
minus r
times
gamma
times d1k
where
d0
and d1
are
sa by sa matrices
okay so instead of writing this
for one element at a time i'm trying to
write it for all elements at a time
and so what i have to do here is that
this d0k will have
zeros along the diagonal except a one at
one point which is this indicator
function
okay
and similarly d1
okay d1 will have a one in the place
where s0
ska k is sa and sk plus 1 ak plus 1 is s
prime a prime
sorry d does not stand for diagonal
uh yeah probably yeah if you want i can
use e here yeah d is diagonal this d0 is
diagonal d1 is not correct you're right
the main reason i wrote it like this is
that if you look at this this looks a
lot like the bellman equation
okay
if i
this
would be
a diagonal matrix
consisting of the stationary
probabilities
of
sa
under policy pi
so this is an indicator function right
now but if you look at this in
expected value
in steady state
okay
if you assume that the system is
stationary which it is not but if it was
stationary then this is just simply
would be just the expected value of the
indicator function s k a k equal s a
which is just simply the probability of
seeing s a
okay so i'm going to indicate this
diagonal matrix
by d pi
[Music]
okay this would be the expected value of
this
and expected value of d 0 k
d 1
k
would be
so this indicator indicates where you
are in the at state k and this indicator
at time k and this this indicates where
you are in time k plus one
right so this will be just simply
the stationary probability
multiplied by the probability transition
matrix
okay
so if i substitute these stationary
probabilities there
then this equation is going to look very
familiar to you after veena's talk
so if i substitute the stationary
probabilities there
which of course is not quite right but
i'm going to do it anyway
sorry this should be epsilon k generally
so i replace
these two by their stationary
expectations of course which is not
correct
and so
i can think of this as this plus n k
where n k is the difference
that's wrong here
the n k is the difference between
the true thing here
and the stationary probe
okay
your commas and ours are looking a
little oh yeah yeah sorry
this should be r i try to write gamma
like this sorry thank you
yeah i have that problem with gammas and
ours
so this is equivalently
so this whole algorithm
can be thought of as another way of
solving the fixed point equation fixed
point equation normally solved by you
start with the q find a new cube by
applying by by setting by running it
through t pi and keep doing this the
fixed point equation just involves these
two but since i don't know
the probability distribution
i do this
okay
and this algorithm is called temporal
difference learning algorithm or td
learning because this is called the
temporal difference the difference
between the right hand side and the left
hand side of the bellman equation
because it's a time where anything is
called a temporal difference algorithm
so this is the basic algorithm in
reinforcement learning where i'm fixing
a policy i'm trying to evaluate the q
function or the value function
associated with it in this particular
case i'm writing it for q function you
can also write the similar thing a
similar thing for the value function b
okay
so our goal is to show
that
this algorithm converges
okay and it's vaguely motivated by
essentially how to estimate the mean of
a random variable
okay
so
the most natural thing to do
would be to study
how
this quantity evolves
right we want to show that
qk converges to q pi
okay so anybody who has taken a course
in control theory for example this would
be called the lyapunov function right
you study the drift of this lyapunov
function and try to show that it goes to
zero or it goes to some small value
whatever
depending on what step sizes you choose
questions
okay
basically why we don't first estimate
the transition matrix and use that but
why we are using this approach
uh
good question so later on we will
in practice you may not even have a
model in this and so you may not even
know how many states there are in your
system so when you do use neural
networks and stuff like that which i'm
not going to talk about i'll try to
approximate
we i mean general people approximate the
q function using a neural network for
example and just you give a state an
action as input it just spits out the q
value and it doesn't need to know
what even the states and actions are
ahead of time to whereas to estimate the
probability transition matrix you need
to know
these are the states in the system these
are the actions in the system so so i
need to estimate the probability
transition matrix
and i don't know if this is another
reason or not but that's a
s a s a square number of elements
here we're just estimating s a elements
q vector is a s a is a vector of
dimension s times a whereas the
probability transition matrix is the
square of that
yeah for each
uh if i'm thinking of the p pi yeah
so but if i put those aside and i said
oh i'm just
i mean it's not feasible is what i'm
trying to say it's feasible for small
problems right for large problems what
we'll do is we won't estimate the q
function like this we would probably
i mean later i'll
say that we're going to try to assume
that q is has some functional form like
this
and try to estimate this theta so phi
would be a set of feature vectors
associated with each state in action for
example if you're playing tetris
right
i assume most of you know what tetris is
you have these blocks that fall and then
you try to knock off things at the
bottom and the state is very complicated
because i mean the the actual shape and
where the holes are and so on is the
state but but a feature vector for this
is kind of easy you can just see the
write down the length of each each
column and where the holes are and
that's a much smaller feature space and
then you try to find a queue function
like so you assume the features are
known associated with each state and
theta typically will be
of some dimension
where d is much much smaller than sa
yes
yeah so you can do you can do this for
policies as well yeah so
no but you could also do it for
transition probability
[Music]
possibly but for whatever reason that
that is not the approach that's taken i
don't know why that's uh
why it is infeasible but but typically
people try to directly estimate the
value function because once you estimate
this
but i think the structure and the
problem if you know something about the
problem then i think exactly what you
said
should be that you should take the
structure
so this is all assuming that there is no
structure in the problem which is not a
very good idea if you for example if you
have a
linear quadratic calcium problem or
something like that where you know that
the problem has some structure then of
course you should take the structure
into account when you resolve the
problem
um
i think this is maybe just like a small
notation that's understanding the
indicator on the like very right hand
side right
uh yeah i don't know i didn't write it
carefully so think of this indicator as
a
product of these doing degas is just uh
so but like i guess where do s prime and
a prime coming from are they are we just
the next state that is okay okay
yeah okay so but like
yeah
are we summing over all s prime and a
prime such that we only yeah
sorry
ah so n k is the difference between
this quantity and the true one
so just here i've taken to remove d0 and
d1 and replace them with
the stationary expectations
right but really it is this this
difference i'm just calling noise
okay
okay so
i want to analyze
that equation
so first i am going to do a noise free
analysis i am going to pretend that
there is no noise in the system
and typically this is the this is the
trajectory of analysis which is
basically you start you write it in this
form where your
q k minus something that's completely
well known and then add everything that
you don't know is noise and then ignore
the noise try to analyze the system and
then try to understand what happens with
system with the noise
okay this is sort of the summary of
everything in institutional
approximation yeah so another notational
clarification question so d0 and d1 are
0 1 matrices that correspond to the
actual realization and this equation is
the correct
exactly this is expectation and these
are these are the actual realizations
sorry the actual the difference between
the actual realization of this is what i
call
okay
okay
so let's
look at the
noise free model
so
the d pi times p pi
maybe i could have just written sk plus
1 ak plus 1 here without putting
indicator
would you
whatever here
expected value of this quantity between
so you write the expectation of a
product that
it's not quite a product of expectations
so this is a stationary distribution and
then this is
a conditional
yeah yeah is this k not just k like the
index this induction decay correct
it's a random matrix n k is a random
vector
whose expectation is zero
conditioned on q
then steady state so it's not
zero at any time but it's zero in steady
state and that's one of the challenges
that we have to overcome
okay so
expected value of
mk
condition on qk
equals 0 if you assume
[Music]
in the stationary region
but it's not and so you have to worry
about that so that's the
crux of the argument for the
noisy case
but first let me look at the noise free
model
uh
so basically to i want to understand the
evolution of
okay all right i want to see whether qk
gets closer and closer to keep heights
right so i'm going to so people call
this the potential function
in computer science literature we have
on our function and control period
picture
so
this is
a painter series but it's very easy to
get a quadratic function here
it won't be this easy for all problems
but since i'm starting with a quadratic
lyapunov function the second derivative
becomes the identity matrix and so this
is
you don't have to write it necessarily
using taylor series because the
quadratic you could have just expanded
this but i'm writing it in this
particular manner because later we'll
see for some other functions
okay
and this is
nothing but wk
plus
2k minus q pi
transpose
what is this quantity in the noise free
case it is just nothing but
epsilon k
times
d phi
that's q k
minus this so what i'm going to do now
is to write q k as q k minus q pi
plus
q pi
minus
t pi
the reason i'm writing it like this is
i want to write this again in terms of q
pi minus
q k
and we know from goena stock that q pi
is nothing but t pi q pi
and so this is nothing but t pi q pi
minus t pi q k and then i'll use some
contraction property to get rid of the t
[Music]
okay
plus
epsilon k square i'm going to put a
m here
it's not very difficult to show that the
cube the td learning algorithm is
bounded
okay so here this is your fact
that uk
i'm going to prove that here so that's a
very straightforward thing to prove
because we are we're taking convex
combinations of
some initial value plus something
bounded so it's always looking fun
yeah
so this is but actually you can do a
more final analysis for the
deterministic case for the noise free
case and get a better result than i'm
going to show here but what i'm going to
show here is what will carry over for
the noisy case
okay so
what do i do now um
everybody see this
okay
okay
so w q k
minus epsilon k
times
the first part is nothing but
q k minus q pi
square except it's a weighted moment
so q k minus 2 pi transpose d pi times q
k minus 2 pi
so it's a weighted tool not weighted by
this matrix d
okay that's the first one here
okay
then what do i do about the second term
so that is
plus epsilon k
pi
okay
so what have i done here
for the second term
what have i used here so i have q q k
minus 2 pi transpose d pi times q pi
minus so it was an inner product
right it's a weighted inner product and
what i'm doing here is the koshi
schwarzenegger
so i'm using the position equality to
write the inner product in terms of the
norm
in terms of two norms
right so again after i use the
contraction property here i will get qk
minus two pi squared
okay plus this m epsilon squared
it's not clear
expanded again
so first term is just
q k minus two pi square weighted by d pi
the second
term is qk minus q pi transpose this
thing with this weight
and so under this weighted inner product
i just write the koshi schwarzenegger
yeah so what is the m here it depends
somehow on the size of d
right so the m is just simply
all i'm saying is that this is a
actually bounded iteration so qk minus 2
pi will be bounded always so the square
of that will be some quantity that's
like epsilon square times some constant
here you can prove that this whole
iteration is bounded as a function of
the initial condition
so this is
this needs a proof
that norm of qk is bounded but it's very
straightforward
yeah i'll get to it a second but but
yeah absolutely has to be some uh i have
to have some conditions for which
let's assume that
mostly and consider this case
but it will also work for other cases
like
it just takes a scripture
there's
right
which is qk minus two pi
base sound is that yes
from this equation q minus 2 epsilon
times b
okay
okay so now
this is further less than or equal to w
q k
okay minus
epsilon k
uh q
minus
q pi
not quite the two norm
but the weighted 2 r
plus
epsilon k
gamma
qk
minus q pi
and this
is due to the fact that
q pi
minus p pi
the same as
p pi
q pi
first part i'm using the fact that q pi
is just nothing but p by 2 pi
minus
t pi
k
with the 2 d prime r
and this
has a contractual property which mean i
did not prove but it also holds
so
wayne approved that
this is a contraction in the insulating
norm also it turns out that for a fixed
policy this is not true for the optimum
optimal weapon operator but the bellman
operator associated with the fixed
policy
is also a contraction
in the weighted uh if the if the norm is
weighted by the stationary distribution
by the way i'm assuming the station the
policy is such that uh
stationary probably being in any state
is possible
okay one zero
so this is
less than
five
2k
plus
yes that inequality is uh specific to
the stationary distribution or
specifically you can only write this by
the station
i don't have a good intuition as to why
that's true so i think basically if you
write this out to prove this it's very
straightforward you just use the kosher
schwartz inequality at one point and use
well actually basically t pi has a uh p
pi and it has to you have to multiply by
d pi multiplied by p pi is like again
can be written in terms of v pi
that's why yeah so you need because the
stationary distribution everyone is
there's a point where you'll have to
multiply with the probability transition
matrix and then you get the stationary
distribution again otherwise
okay
so now we have business
so w
q k plus one
is less than or equal to w q k
times 1 minus
epsilon k times
1 minus gamma
times
so notice that this is a weighted tumor
because w
is is the unweighted tuner
so therefore to get rid of it i have to
uh because there's a minus sign here
i have to
i use the smallest value the diagonal so
i'm just calling that b
so this is it
i mean if epsilon k is constant let's
take that case epsilon k is constant of
course this is a stable recursion if
epsilon is sufficiently small so that's
less than 1 minus
1 over 1 minus gamma times d min
okay in which case you can show that w
2k converges
so
if if
epsilon is epsilon and small enough
then
satisfying those conditions and you can
show that it actually goes to zero okay
actually in this particular case in the
deterministic case you can actually show
that this goes to zero even for the
fixed epsilon but because i did this
true approximation here you can't see
that but you
so can you explain again where demon
comes from and
so it is just basically i'm replacing
this quantity here
uh uh i'm just saying that uh
minus q2 ah right double w is an odd way
to tune two-norm correct right okay so
this is this is the weight
sorry
that's greater than
[Music]
so reinforcement learning you need
exploration right okay like in chip
stock i mean you you need exploration
for multi-arm bandits so the policies
you try are typically randomized
policies which allow you to explore
every state action space so we
we want to design policies to guarantee
correct
exactly so i'm assuming there's a policy
that is randomized and we'll miss it all
state action
all right uh more cleaner connections
winston crosstalk
reinforcement learning will be in seance
talk later this afternoon
but do you need that to estimate just to
estimate
you might need that to optimize correct
yeah
but do you need that
yeah if you're interested in just
estimating the value function associated
with it
you don't you don't need that
i mean for q by u if you want to
estimate q pi for every state action but
of course you need it
it depends on what you so so if you're
interested in estimating v pi of s
you just need to make sure that every
state is facilitated if you're
interested in q pi
of test comma a for every sna
okay i guess if some states are some
states and actions are not visited maybe
you don't require it but i'm not sure
what will happen
here
because of this uh
norm's not matching it might be a
problem but for anyway this is just a
one piece of trying to learn the optimal
policy and when you're trying to learn
the optimal policy you need to explore
every essay for that reason i'm just
considering those kind of purposes
okay
okay so now let me look at the noisy
case
as i said if i did a more careful
analysis actually it will go to zero in
this case but i didn't
yeah but but if you if you even in this
lazy analysis you can make it towards
zero so on pages
just like your first order method for
finding the fixed point of a contraction
correct essentially that so it's in the
second part you have to worry about the
noise
and then we'll figure it out
is there any more modern treatment
people think about these as some sort of
person that could know the southern
point of temptation
even this is this and uh
finite time bounce for this are very new
actually only in 2019 so
typically what people used to do is that
they used to write this in terms of the
expected value of this condition of the
past it's less than equal to this and
then they would use the super martini
numbers there to show synthetic
stability
so in the scope 29 so much of my
presentation is based on this
it's a simplified
presentation
uh as you can see this gets more and
more complicated as you as you as you
when you try to learn the
uh
optimum q function
or if you're trying to do policy
iteration or value iteration based
methods to compute the optimal function
yeah
yeah this is very basic
this this these ideas were also used in
the original i mean i should say
sensitless and android
so asymptotic convergence
meaning a scale goes to infinity instead
of being able to provide finite time
bounce they will just essentially then
appeal to the supermarket convergence
theorem to
show asymptotic components
so what is the how do we deal with noise
and this is markovian nox if it's iid
noise can be very simple
but we have markovian noise
right
so the markovian noise 10k
is
we have this nk
so the main difficulty is figuring out
how to deal with this
okay because nk is not an iid
quantity it's a very complicated
quantity but what we do know about this
is that expected value of d0
is
a d pi
i mean in steady state an expected value
of d0
times d1
is this
stationary expectations
have this
yeah
isn't this the other way around the
thing written in mk
because i thought that the mk was the
difference between the
right
plus cfa because the minus
so what do we do about this
okay
so now
so what will happen
is
if i do w 2 k plus 1
minus w q k
ok
so this
will have
the same terms as before
plus
the gradient of
w q k
times epsilon n k
and then there will be it will also
appear in the quadratic term but that
will still be order epsilon k square so
i'm going to absorb it here so i'm just
calling just redefining that m that i
had here and just calling it mk state
so this is the term we have to worry
about
okay
so if we can show
that this quantity is part of okay yeah
this quantity is order epsilon squared
in some sense
then we'll have a similar result like
this
okay but of course it's not going to be
true in a deterministic sense so it can
only be true in some stochastic sense
right
so what i'm going to do
is okay so
i think most of you probably
know this concept
so if i call
let me just write it somewhere
hmm
so
okay so
we have to somehow exploit the property
that in stationarity the expected value
of d zero is d pi
okay
but but that's not
that can't be but when you're trying to
do a finite time analysis like this
you can't rely on that so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to say if you run the
system for sufficiently long period of
time at least for tau if so on amount of
time okay then the expected value of b
zero is going to be epsilon close to d
pi the total variation distance so if
you just because it's only diagonal so
you're comparing two probability
distributions and then so therefore in
the total variation distance so this
if you don't know what this is just
think of it as cell epsilon is the
amount of time that it takes for for
uh uh
this distribution to get close to the
stationary solution that's what's called
unique subjective expectations so i said
it's pollution that
d0 okay seems to be yeah but but that's
uh so so the diagonal element
will be a bunch of expectations each of
them of an indicator function so there's
already probabilities
i see so i think of it actually
the the space in which you take the
variation is just the vector space
the diagonal elements
yes
one
yes because it's uh
one of them will be one and the rest of
them will be zero
yeah d pi is the stationary distribution
by differential
diagram
yeah because
i just take the expectation condition to
uk and then say you have a martingale
sequence that you use
like the inequality that you have the
difference between w cube k plus or
minus seventy fifty k
uh after you add the noise that take the
expectation function
but this won't be if you conditionally q
k d case d one may not be close to d pi
so
if you condition on qk
d0 will not be close to d bar
because of the one step difference
so
but that but you've got an idea
basically so what you have to do is so
if you
yeah but i think his question is that
why not condition this one
so if you consider the essentially
distribution then they're going to be
equal right now you're going to have
something that you know
the past then at the current time will
be close to the station institution
okay
so this requires uh
some
algebra here
right try to outline so so nk consists
of all of these terms let me take one of
the terms in mk
nk consists of many
[Music]
and k is like this right
so if i look at this the different so
it's the difference between these two
things i'm just looking at the different
first terms here okay you have the same
analysis can be carried out
so when i look at gradient of
wk
transpose nk with an epsilon in front
we'll get epsilon
q k
minus q pi
transpose
qk which
is
approximately epsilon
times qk minus tau
minus q by
d pi
minus d0
handy writing everything here
i'm going to replace qk by qk minus tau
but qk minus l and qk differ it's it's
tau over you're summing up over k you're
looking at the difference between qk and
qk minus tau and since each time you're
adding a bounded quantity the amount
that will be different by is this
epsilon times star
let me just consider the fixed steps in
our cases
okay
so so you have an extra term like this
and then this now these two are
ordered epsilon close if you condition
on
hk minus
history up to not at the current time
but the condition of the past epsilon
then d pi will be close to this expected
value of d0 when you condition on h
k minus tau will be close to
d pi and so this whole thing can be
shown to be order epsilon square
condition dot x
so basically what i'm saying here is
this is a lot of
a lot of stuff here but this this part
is
the
computations are somewhat cumbersome but
what you can show
is
will be turned on
[Music]
something like that
exactly the same thing hand
so the first condition on hk minus tau
and then take expectations again to
uncondition it and then after you
uncondition it you'll get it
so now it becomes essentially electric
deterministic problem
or sufficiently small epsilon a little
too much yeah
um
the
when you said when you head wave to go
from k to k minus tau
is that uh
what what was the big intuition behind
that oh
this this is uh
so each time you're adding this much
so in power time units
oh and there's a times tau i think yeah
i didn't see that okay cool
sorry this should be multiplied by
epsilon
and this for those of you know about
mixing time will be at the part of the
log of our epsilon
so it's not quite epsilon squared
anymore but it's epsilon square times
okay
assuming
assuming you know what so you need you
need to so i'm assuming that
my transition probability matrix for
this policy is irreducible
yeah
so it has a stationary distribution does
a mixing time has everything that nice
things that you need yeah
so that's why a good exploratory policy
is needed
the power is up
uh so this is the basic stuff so this is
3d learning and so we will build upon
this ideas to
figure out what the optimal pulse is
okay
that'll be the second part
any other questions
and you need to make sure that you
explore the entire thing and how does
that work how do you kind of make sure
that you
i mean in real life probably all you
just give us the tricks
but if you have the ability to
design a policy you probably do a
randomized policy
and the policy is randomized you just
hope that
and you use that there's a randomized
policy that visits every
uh action that takes every action
it's a nonzero probability then that
hopefully you can use the whole reaction
matrix that that's the
but it works
yeah
exploratory policy in many cases people
have made you know things like getting
more efficient like this and so on so
so this you're talking about
yeah so that's why i'm worried about
words
of utility
yes there is some recent work by
martin wainwright and uh
one doing this but uh um
i haven't looked at it carefully so but
that is what my
i must also say that
very closely related to our paper
and done a little bit before our paper
is actually this
they assume a projection step which we
know that that's the main difference
so
definitely reading that paper as well
[Music]
yeah maybe this is a stupid question but
what are the conclusions we can get from
the last question
oh so you can show that uh
so from this you can show that
this
limit
is
order epsilon to use 6 steps along
if you use epsilons that satisfy these
kind of conditions you can actually show
that it goes to zero
but what about like central complexity
sample complexity
now
so this will this will be some
constant times
you can write a
so from this you can conclude
that this
is less than or equal to
i have to choose epsilon or you can use
this if you use epsilon equals 1 over
k for example then instead of this you
can prove a result of this form
so one nasty thing here is that this
depends on demand
the demand will be very very small right
so so it's exponentially converging but
then it's convolving very very slowly
but you can get a one over t itself
without actually the any dependence on
the english
sort of like uh
an optimization right i mean you either
get an exponential convergence or fixed
step size or or if you use one over t
step size and you get one over t
convergence so i imagine this will
become important
yes yes so when you're using this
inside
another another algorithm to find the
optimal policy then yes all of this
means
it's somewhere between exponential but
very very slowly or one over t without
depending
right but suppose at the end of the day
i just want to know
the arc max
i'm saying in general if i don't really
care about the q matrix i just care
about the largest value
yes
so that is this is sort of
i mean
this is sort of like the variance term
right this is a quadratic term and this
is obvious to me how for constant step
size is that
when the sounds of variances go to
infinity
so you can prove this that the limit of
this
is the expectation
this
is like
[Music]
yeah
i mean it's like an optimization where
epsilon's chosen is less than one over l
or whatever so if you know the function
is
okay should we take a break and come
back
if